what's going on guys you know this has
been a really weird year for sequels
read to kick-ass 2 Percy Jackson another
Smurfs movie are these the sequels that
we have been demanding No
today we're gonna tell you the sequels
that need to be made we have a pretty
cool panel to help us figure that out
first
down at the end he has a new book it's a
comedic adventure called crap kingdoms
super funny DC Pierson hey guys I'm also
a sequel and Donald Charles Pearson the
fourth technically oh I feel qualified
to speak on this and like most sequels
I'm worse than the original and sitting
right next to me
he is a Rotten Tomatoes certified film
critic you can check them out on
youtube.com slash schmoes know he's one
of the schmoes Mark Ellis I am also a
sequel I hit Mark Ellis jr. and much
like the second film in Star Wars my dad
once tried to cut my hand off so we're
talking sequels I'm gonna start us off a
sequel that I would like to see made is
unbreakable I feel like I remember
seeing pretty recently I can't member
what he was promoting but Samuel Jackson
was talking about how he was excited to
do the next unbreakable movie with the
mr. glass character because he is a sort
of set up at the end of unbreakable if
you haven't seen it yet I'm sorry it's
not the biggest sport yeah and give you
someone actually got mad when I spoiled
six cents on this show there should be
the way that things go into like public
domain after a while they should have
that for spoilers where there's a thing
where Congress announces like okay it's
now in you know spoiled territory I
would go ahead and greenlight an
unbreakable sequel just because it would
stop bruce willis from making another
diehard if I have to see Bruce in a
sequel it's doing breakable to as
opposed to whatever the next trainwreck
thigh hardened yeah I believe Willis has
said that he is like tired of doing
movies with like guns and explosions and
that was the sort of interesting thing
about the about unbreakable is that it
was a comic book superhero movie where
everyone just talked in whispers and
like lightly shoved each other I think
you could have just stopped at Bruce
Willis is tired of making movies mark
what do you want to see well we still
have to wait another 30 years for the
next 50 years storm but we should not
have to wait that long for point
break2 are you kidding me if we have the
hologram technology we can CGI Patrick
Swayze back into this thing we need to
know what happened to Special Agent
Johnny Utah if you really want to go
that route I think you have to make it a
mash-up of ghosts
Point Break what would Point Break - we
called Point Break - well if you go the
football route which I want canta Reeves
to regain his quarterback abilities in
play and the NFL and the Super Bowl so
you could call it Point Break extra
point or Point Break into electric
Boogaloo we should probably have a
sequel with the electric Boogaloo
tagline so what better Phillip point
Frank DC the first one on my list is a
very recent release potentially the most
recent release of any of the ones we're
gonna mention today Pacific Rim has not
been greenlit for a sequel it was a
really good movie but it was a really
great setting of the table for
potentially an awesome franchise of
giant monsters and giant robots fighting
each other totally so do they reopen
that portal any time God closes a portal
through which monsters come through he
opens a window through which monsters
come through Oh what would you call the
next Pacific Rim I just have a I don't
know what I personally would call it I
just have a feeling with the way that
sequel titles are trending it's always
like the name of the first movie :
legacy of the rise of the fallen of the
fear of the terror of the robots of the
aliens it's catchy
it's a hashtag it's a good hashtag okay
next movie I'm gonna go I would love to
see inception there's just so many
places you could take that and so many
crimes and the one dream that they never
really covered which I think we can all
relate to the most is when you're naked
you're in high school and you have to go
do a high school play that evening but
you forgot your lines that's one thing
they didn't do an inception go into any
like weird goofy dreams yeah there was
never like that I just always have the
one where I'm falling and you kind of
got that a little bit when they're
floating around in the hotel room just
for a shot like that alone I can go see
another inception from what I understand
avatar sequel is gonna the first avatar
sequel is gonna take place under water
so if they go that route with it it
could be Inception - wet dream or maybe
inception - what dreams may come that's
somehow dirtier than the one I just said
mark I'm gonna go a little more
old-school and I'm gonna say Beetlejuice
- I don't know why beetlejuice - didn't
happen initially fitting enough time has
gone
I may be Michael Keaton can come back as
an older Beetlejuice training a younger
Beetlejuice played by Zac Efron no what
would you call a new installment of
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice that's a tough
Beetlejuice ear I feel like you used to
be beetle tooth with a tube beetle -
yeah as long as it's not that matte like
the masks equal and son of Beetlejuice
mmm I feel like we could get into that
territory so easily that's a that's a
slippery slope Jamie Kennedy do not play
Beetlejuice no stone DC my second one
was the Fifth Element
again Bruce Willis actually giving a
which is always a total joy to
watch it would be tough for it to
disappoint to me because I don't know
what it would be I just know that that
would be neat what would we call the
next installment of film well you
wouldn't want to call it the sixth
element because then we would all know
from the beginning that korben Dallas
was a ghost spoiler alert
what movie do you want to see what we
leave off the list please let us know in
the comments section below best answer
does a screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank my delightful panel DC Pierson
pick up his book crap Kingdom in stores
now Mark Ellis youtube.com slash schmoes
know subscribe subscribe to us if you
haven't already and thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye are you
guys excited about the screen junkies
show one year anniversary never heard of
it haven't seen it I don't know a screen
junkies I have no idea what that is I
don't even know what that is
are you a fan of Hal Rudnick who's that